>> DAVID: ...and Mindy from Intuit, who are
going to show you how, using pretty much exactly
the same integration points, they've taken
a business critical application, Payroll,
and used the same technical capabilities that
we just demo'd on a toy app to solve a real
business problem, which is Payroll, and to
do that in a way that is well integrated with
Google Apps and part of the family of Apps.
So, Martin.
>> MARTIN: Great, thanks, David. So you probably--many
of you may know Intuit. Maybe you don't know
that Intuit is the largest or most popular
payroll service provider in the nation. We
have about a million customers right now having
their payroll provided by Intuit. And some
of them using our online service that we're
gonna show here. The kind of customers we
serve, they're usually very small customers--five,
six, seven employees there. When you went
to a sandwich shop today to get your lunch
or you go to a coffee shop, those are the
kind of people who use our service, and there's
about 6 million employers in the U.S. Most
of 'em are the smaller end of the market,
less than 20 employees. So here this is the
page that we were just looking at. Are we
on the demo now? We're ready for that. So
that we can add our app. There we go. So Mindy's
adding the application just like David showed,
but this is ours, of course. We have the same
set of clicks, the terms of service. We agree
and continue. The next step is data access.
We have the calendar access 'cause we're gonna
put some stuff about your payroll--when your
paydays are in particular in the employees
calendar and the employers calendar. That's
some user provisioning. And then we enable
the app. So that's all quite quick and straightforward.
There is the setting up of the payroll, which
takes a little bit longer. You have to put
in all the employees. We're not gonna demo
that today, so we're gonna switch over to
another company now where we've already set
up the payroll stuff and show you how the
payroll works inside of Google Apps. So here
it typically starts where you get an email
from us reminding you that it's time to do
your payroll. We'll go to the universal nav
up there on the top and click on Intuit Online
Payroll. And in our case, we've chosen to
have you reenter your same credentials for
your Google Apps. Just there's some confidential
data in Payroll, as you can imagine. We just
want to make sure that's all safe and the
right person looking at it. And here we go.
So this is the to-do list. We will show you,
typically, what you would do with your taxes
and your forms. In this case, there's not
a lot to do other than--oh, look at that.
Somebody--Mindy wants a raise. What's that,
Mindy? So we're just gonna go straight to
Payday and skip that giving her a raise business.
But we will put in some hours for Mindy so
that she gets paid for this week, and then
create the paychecks. Up they come. And that's
it. Paychecks are calculated. You can see
that the numbers are all right, that a small
business would typically approve them at that
point. And there's a few more steps. They
can print them out if they want to. They can
also send email to the employees to let them
know their payroll's available. So that's
it. Payroll's done. We really focus on that,
making it simple to do Payroll, and with the
integration with Google Apps, it's simple
to use the same credentials that you already
use. In this case, we're also gonna have Mindy
show that she just got paid and how she can
see her pay stub. Mindy?
>> MINDY: Yes. So I am buying a new car, a
Jetta TDI, and Volkswagen, in order to approve
my auto loan, needs a copy of my latest pay
stub as proof of employment, so let me show
you how easy it is to get my pay stub through
Google Apps. I'm gonna log into my calendar.
Hmm. Wanted to make this experience feel real.
>> MARTIN: If anyone would like to make guesses
about what that CAPTCHA says. She might be
accepting...
>> MINDY: So that was so easy. I get to my
calendar, and you can see I have a little
paycheck icon on my last payday. So I can
click on this to view my pay stub. In the
past, I would have had to track it down on
my own records or bug my employer to get my
pay stub. But now because of the integration
between Google Apps and Intuit's employee
website, I can actually just log in directly
to my calendar and get right to my pay stub.
I can print it right from here. And I'm done.
It's that easy.
>> MARTIN: So we're really excited to be part
of this Marketplace. The same kind of businesses
that use Google Apps are the ones that use
our payroll solution, and we're just looking
forward to adding more to what we've already
started here today. David.
>> DAVID: Thank you.
So what you just saw is Intuit using some
very simple points of integration to the Marketplace,
building their payroll application into the
Google Apps family, so it feels just like
part of the family. Good luck with that loan.
I hope they help you get your car. So... I'd
like to bring up our next demo now. So I'm
going to be introducing Scott from Atlassian
who flew in earlier today from the other side
of the world, and Scott's gonna show us the
demo of integration that uses a lot of different
points of integration, a lot of the different
extension points, to show how their entire
suite of development tools can be connected
with lots of different points of connection
with Google's suite of communication and collaboration
tools. Scott.
>> SCOTT: Thanks, David. My name's Scott Farquhar,
and I'm really excited to be here to demonstrate
the integration we've built. Atlassian sells
software development tools to 17,000 companies
worldwide, and we've built kick-ass integration
between Google Apps and our online hosted
development suite, JIRA Studio. Today you're
gonna see the best integrated product in the
Google Marketplace. Let's consider our software
development team. Say that I'm a project manager--and
I'll switch to the demo now. Say I'm a project
manager. I spend all my day in email, and
what I really want is the information about
my projects delivered to me directly in email.
You can see on the left-hand side of the screen
here, we've got a list of issues that are
assigned to me. Now this list of issues comes
directly from JIRA studio and uses the gadget
technology to embed it inside Gmail. With
one click, I can get more information about
this issue and interact with it directly.
We can see on this particular issue the technical
lead on the project can't start development
because we're missing the design specification.
Now because our company is standardized on
Google Docs for all our information, it's
simple to simply click through to search for
and attach the design specification to this
issue. We think that this integration is gonna
save a whole heap of time for companies that
use Google Docs as well as JIRA Studio. Let's
instead take a different member of the software
project. Let's take the software development
lead. Now, while the development lead starts
their day in Gmail, they quickly want to dive
into Studio to get some work done. Now using
the universal navigation bar described earlier,
we can click through and, using the open ID
integration, not have to re-log in. Now many
of you will be familiar with JIRA, the number
one issue tracking system. JIRA combines the
power of-- well, Studio combines the power
of JIRA with Wiki, Source Code, Code Review,
and Continuous Integration in one online hosted
development suite. Now you can see here with
the dashboard for JIRA Studio, it's an iGoogle-like
dashboard. And we've used the same technology
that Google uses, the same open social technology,
in our products, and that means that we can
take Google boards and Google gadgets and
embed them directly inside this dashboard,
as you can see with the Google Translate gadget
that we have. Of course, you can also take
Studio gadgets and display them inside Google
applications such as iGoogle or Gmail, like
you saw previously. Now the power of Studio
is that we've got all these development applications
in one suite, and on the left-hand side, you
can see the list of recent activity across
the entire development tools. Let's quickly
jump through to the issue that we saw earlier.
Now because I'm the technical lead, I want
to take this design specification and ensure
that it's complete before I send it to my
developers to begin work. Now with a simple
click, I can quickly review this document
without leaving Studio, without having to
re-authenticate or log in. I can review this
document, and if I need to make any changes,
with one click I'll be sent straight to Google
Docs where I can make those changes, and they'll
be reflected in real time. We think again
this is going to save a whole heap of time.
So just to recap what we've shown you, we've
shown you putting gadgets from Gmail-- sorry,
gadgets from Google inside Studio and gadgets
from Studio inside Gmail. And we've shown
you that the real power of the integration
for Google Docs. But the thing I'm most excited
about is the Studio activity bar. The Studio
activity bar is at the bottom of every page
in Studio. And on the left-hand side gives
you fingertip access to all the applications
in Studio and all the applications in Google
Apps. And on the right-hand side, we've integrated
Google Talk. So Google Talk allows me to instantly
collaborate with my colleagues and let them
know what's--you know, what they need to do
next. So in this particular case, this feature's
ready to work--ready to begin work. So I'm
gonna send it to Dan the developer and, using
our permalink feature, I can instantly send
him the page that we're working on. Now of
course this saves us a whole heap of time
of jumping back and forth between applications
and searching for the people in our team.
So here we've sent information to Dan, and
then we have to set up a meeting to discuss
with him later. Now we think this integration
of Chat between your colleagues is incredibly
powerful. But we didn't to stop there. We
thought, well, what can we do to take advantage
of this integration between JIRA Studio...